okay so a man in florida was walking his
dog he has this tiny little it looks
like a chihuahua
a juvenile alligator came up and grabbed
it because the dog wasn't on a leash
this man jumped into the swamp and
wrestled the alligator until
its jaws open and release the dog my
girl sent me this last night let me see
that's very sad oh it's a little one
yeah it's little ones
means there's big ones
oh yeah he's gonna snap
he's gonna snap the alligator back
what's he doing with it no just kidding
no he's just
no it's the end doesn't really show him
like getting out
the man did an interview and said that
his dog was fine he only had
a like a small puncture on his leg but
his hands are like all chewed up now
well look how he came out chalk that up
as a loss my dog gets bit by now
i love you i love you but look how he
came out the water like undertaking
coming out the casket like this
he had some pipes
for the beginning the alligator's like
what the [ __ ]
that dude's gangster man because because
there's other alligators in that water
yes no
they ain't just wanted this is in
florida this is in florida yeah yeah
they all love you must really love that
dog
oh you're gonna go back wow i guarantee
you tell that story well listen i had my
first wife jesus christ
gave me the puppy she passed away so i
figured damn
it's a southern john wick is that what
you're saying southern his name richard
well my name is richard wilbanks
my dog gunner went down there in the
lake and he told him to stay down okay
all right well all right how about when
i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song